how do you think you will die and do you
think you'll be during a video probably
doing something dumb like going to space
when I'm in the older like trying to go
to Mars or something like that I know
for a fact it won't be on a video every
video we do with safety experts and
stuff like that so it's not really risk
but
um yeah I could see myself like you know
after a million people go to Mars or
something like that I'd probably like
you know what let's go and and something
like that maybe so not in the name of a
video just not for the holiday heck no
are you open to taking risks when you
shoot videos you just went to Antarctica
I mean like you're you're putting
yourself in the line a little bit right
of course but you know we we've had that
video in the works for three years and
then we consult with tons of experts
radar the entire path we're gonna walk
beforehand to see if there's crevasses
so we know there's no crevasses we do
training we consult with experts and we
have survival guides there with us and
you know monitor the weather and
everything so it's like any variable
that where we could get harmed we just
pre-planned for it same thing with
buried alive like I had David Blaine
spent a week underground and so I
consulted with him and consulted with
basically anyone who ever buried
themselves alive you know the coffin we
used to bury me we did so many tests
like that coffin was buried 10 times
before I was you know for way longer
than 50 hours it tested the airflow and
everything to the point where I was
safer in that coffin underground than I
was above ground like so we just tend to
just not leave anything up to chance you
know
another strange question then
so you've recorded these videos
to yourself you know five years ten
years from now have you recorded a video
that's to be released once you die
well first off I am just glad that not
every one of your questions have to do
with like views or things like that it's
nice getting different questions so this
is this is good uh no seriously stuck
but it's fine because a lot of people
just be like how much money do you make
you know it's just something I just
everything's always about money now for
when people talk to me so it's nice
um but for the videos I made uh for you
guys who probably don't follow me too
closely when I had 8 000 subscribers and
I was a teenager I filmed a bunch of
videos and scheduled them years in the
future and I said I'd filmed one where I
was like hi me in a year and the video
went up a year later and it was just
like hey I think you'll have a hundred
thousand subscribers and then I did one
where I was like hire me in five years I
was like Hey in five years I think
you'll have a million and then one that
hasn't come out yet but comes out in two
years is was high me in 10 years and I
try to predict 10 years later how many
Subs I'd have that's what he's referring
to and yes there there are some that are
scheduled like 20 years in the future
and so if I don't die I'll just move
them up and I remember because I filmed
these though like seven years ago go but
uh it was I remember saying a line like
you know if I'm dead then I'm currently
just in a coffin and like whatever blah
blah because the only way the video go
up is if I'm not alive and if I'm not
alive then I won't be able to push back
to schedule upload date so go public
automatically yes and so yeah I have a
couple of those uh like if I knew I was
gonna die of like
cancer or something I had like three
months to live I would Vlog every day
I'd film so many videos and then I would
just schedule upload a video a week for
like the next five years so it's like
I'm still alive and I would completely
act like I'm still alive and everything
and I think something like that would be
cool
it's I don't know why but I've fantasize
not fantasize but I've dreamed about
that a lot like I don't know if if I
only had 30 days to live what would I do
and for me I would try to make like a
decades worth of content and schedule
upload it so they automatically go
public in the future and so it's just
like I never died I'm just there
yeah it's a kind of immortality but it's
also kind of troll on the concept of
time yeah that you can die in the
physical space but persist in the
digital space I actually I recorded a
video like that because I had some
concerns and I just thought it's also a
good exercise to do a video would like
to be released if I die
and it was actually a really interesting
exercise it's cool like it shows like
what you really care about I guess it's
like writing a will but when you're
younger you don't think about that kind
of stuff but exactly mine was just dumb
yeah like I'm bones in a coffin yeah
yours is probably so serious no it's fun
actually well you realize it's like
there's no point to be serious at this
point it's a weird thing I guess you've
done this but it's a weird thing to
address the world when you the
physically you is no longer there so
like you know this would only be
released if you're no longer there
exactly that's a weird exercise you know
what's funny of all the people listening
to this yeah you know we're probably the
only two people that have made videos
for when we die it's like such a niche
thing and the fact that we're bonding
over it's kind of funny I think people
should think about doing that it's not
just about YouTube it's also social
media because think about it like
there's going to be a last tweet and the
last I don't know Facebook post their
last Instagram post
and uh
yeah I feel like there's some aspect
that's meditative to just even
considering making a post like that and
also it's a way for your the people that
love you to kind of like celebrate do
you think that would help them cope or
not like if someone randomly watching
this did film a video you know for if
they accidentally died in some freak
accident to be given to their family do
you think that would and it was like a
genuine I think it would really help I
mean it depends because like how would
you even intro that like hey Mom if
you're seeing this you know it means I'm
probably dead yeah exactly that's how
you enjoy it that's the opener oh I just
want you to know yeah I guess yeah and I
guess you could say in a kind of funny
way but um and just talk about the
things that you that mean a lot to you
because otherwise you're at the risk of
the last post you have is like like I
don't know talking [ __ ] about like
McDonald's McDonald's exactly and then
you're dead that's it 100 years
I don't know this I I do recommend it's
it's uh like the stoics meditate on
death every day in the same way you kind
of meditate in your death when you make
a video like that because it's actually
not just even talking to yourself it's
talking to the world and it like for
some reason at least for me they made it
very concrete that there's going to be
an end
and I'm like
it's almost it's over for me if I'm
making the video it's over for me it's
just an interesting thought experiment I
recommend people
um uh try it okay uh from Are You Afraid
Of Death By the way yes I I
it's hard because
like what if you just die and then you
just see nothing forever you know yeah
the nothingness it just Fades to
Blackness and you're just like that for
trillions upon trillions to billion
squared years and it's just it's scary
but also before you're born you don't
remember those what x amount of years
either so
um that gives me a little Comfort but no
it's definitely very scary something I'd
rather not think about until I'm like
80. I'll deal with that problem then I I
don't know if I told you this but I'm
kind of hopeful that someone like Elon
or one of these like freak smart people
will just like be like you know what
screw it I'm gonna figure out a way
where we can slow down aging get over
you know we can live to be two 300 years
old and just like set their sights on
that and then just kind of save us so be
really nice like it's it's almost absurd
to think that in our lifetime they won't
figure out a way to just even slightly
slow down aging where we could live to
be like 120 or 130 and then that extra
time they won't figure out somewhere we
could live to be 200. like obviously not
Immortal but I don't I don't see how in
my lifetime the life expectancy doesn't
just expand well it also could be that
the immortality is achieved in the
digital realm like it could be long be
long after you're gone there's a Mr
Beast run by Chad gbt type system
exactly yeah that consumes everything I
ever said everything I ever wrote and
thought I don't want that I want to live
what are you smart people out there
figure it out I'll keep you entertained
but I need you to figure out how to keep
me alive
give me until 200. that will make me
happy
well that's that's funny who owns the
identity of of Mr Beast wants the
physical body's gone like is it illegal
to create another Mr Beast that's Chad
GPT based I don't know what the laws are
around that yeah like I mean once I'm
done I don't care well but you just said
you did care I mean there could be a AI
like many Mr beasts that are created
after after you're gone yeah I mean that
would be cool to be able to like train
up a model and and let them loose so my
content lives on I guess yeah yeah but
it somehow feels like it diminishes the
video you contribute yeah yeah it's
inauthentic but it's also
there's there's some aspect to the
finiteness of the art
being necessary for it yeah I want the
second that thing starts spamming out
videos the videos lose all meaning and
it's pointless and it's a money grab